[Music]
you seem like an optimistic guy to me
would you would you consider yourself
optimistic
well the alternative sucks so
we'll see more about that because i
think it's
i've seen various and i
i can't cite these sources here but
polls and surveys of especially younger
people like 20 to 35
maybe even younger who
have record levels of apathy right and
pessimism yes that's a problem that is a
very very significant problem especially
when you consider you know a lot of the
entrepreneurs who are going to be in the
full contact kind of professional sports
of business do a lot of great work in
that band right
so
and whether that is doesn't have to be
in the in the for-profit sector but just
people getting big things done in the
world fall a lot of them fall in that
band
how do you cultivate optimism or how
would you sell optimism to people who
are feeling apathetic when they're just
getting barraged all day long by what
they consider to be fatalistic bad news
well first
change your media diet
yeah first change your media diet and
start talking and listening to people
who actually have some
possible
solutions for the problems
now that you're tuned into the problems
that some of the problems we have go
learn about them go see how you can be
part of the solution so either you can
sit there and be apathetic
and be part of the problem or you can
move and be part of the solution right
apathy doesn't sit in the middle between
problem and solution if you are
apathetic you're part of the problem
you need to be working on the solutions
and more that you look at the solutions
and i'm seeing things for 5 7 10 years
out 15 years out
you can't help it be optimistic because
you see the stuff that's coming down
through you know from these research
labs or from these brilliant
entrepreneurs who have great ideas and
some will fail of course but a lot of
them will succeed and you start going oh
my god there is a future we can do this
if we want to embrace it we saw it with
kovit we all got together at covent just
two years ago like this week or last
week oh my god we're putting up
temporary hospitals what can we do about
testing what are we doing about new ways
of communicating the data and getting
the news stories out there and and of
course there was
misinformation all the other stuff but
look at how the world rallied together
and tried to figure this stuff out
governments did and you're like you
might even feel at least i did here in
europe a sense of leadership from the
politicians and the governments of
trying even if you might not agree
trying to do something about it
when you see that we do have that
capability as humans to help each other
and help our own as well as each other
when we know that there are climate
crisis problems out there and when you
start to see the solutions it's hard to
be
it's hard to be pessimistic or apathetic
about it because again if you are then
you're not helping to solve it right
you're not helping to be on that side be
on the other side helping to solve it
and maybe you'll see something i'm a
cautious optimist okay i'm not just a
create i used to be an optimistic
optimist i'm a cautious optimist right
or a pessimistic optimist i make sure we
pick things because there's lots of
things to pick from that can be real and
help those become real but i obviously
ask all the questions it's just not like
oh yeah that's going to be great no we
have to really dive in there's a lot of
shady people out there selling things
that don't really exist but when you
start to get on the other side of the
equation and start to look for solutions
then you can start to get optimistic so
change your media diet first and
foremost start learning think about
things you're passionate about and dive
in and learn because there's so many
resources out there you wouldn't believe
how many things are out there and people
are needed for those and they're usually
really well paying too and you're gonna
do something that's meaningful to you
to your family maybe your kids or
grandkids and it's gonna help your
society and it's going to help the
planet so that when you sit at a dinner
table in 2050 with your grandkids or
whoever it is and they go oh my god we
just got past this climate crisis issue
it's always going to be lingering with
us but we got past it and your
kids or your generations people around
the table go what did you do about it
how did you solve it personally or
professional how are you part of the
solution you can actually have really
good answers
because this is an existential thing
this is not about [ __ ] metamers or
the craziness around the nft you know
gambling
this is about true problems that we have
and to your earlier point the first
trillionaire will be someone who solves
these massive problems on this planet
that we have because why because we're
not going to exist without them and
that's the biggest pain ever think about
this when you get sick or i hope you
never do but when someone gets sick what
happens they all of a sudden go
i'm gonna change my life i you know they
have a heart attack who knows what it is
god forbid anything happening but
i'm gonna change my life i'm gonna go in
and they wake up to it well guess what
we have a sick planet our planet is
incredibly sick and we caused it nobody
else did we cause it maybe it's other
generations but you can't just sit
around and go well it's sick i don't
know what to do it's a family member
it's so important it's a family member
what are you doing to be on the right
side and trying
to to find solutions both personally and
professional
you're here
it's a passion man i i love this no i
know this is why i want to bring it up
you